The Irish contestants,
Aleksandra Amini is an avid tennis
player.
He hasn't been to the software that
analyzes tennis trucks and gives details
feedback to athletes so that they can
improve their performance.
No,
my.
My Algorithm is monitoring the initial
data from the center until I had a
stroke.
I will,
once I hit the stroke,
it will protect the stroke and then try
and process each of the possible stroke
types I could have possibly been hit
once a stroke is a process.
This process by its provided back to the
athlete by feedback and also a precise
and unbiased feedback is provided based
on small deviations that were performed
and that could be used to improve the
stroke for the next time.
That was it.